we begin tonight the walls are caving in
around the deep state and tonight we can
absolutely
positively report a pivotal document
release
is only days away we're talking about
transcripts
specific transcripts from the fbi's top
secret surveillance of the trump
campaign age george papadopoulos and
george carter
this at the height of the 2016 election
papadopoulos will be here
in a moment to preview this major
development
he used exculpatory language and we
actually have the tapes
and transcripts and according to our
sources this is groundbreaking
information
filled with copious amounts of
exculpatory evidence in other words
obama's doj comey's fbi
they had a mountain of information
proving that trump
russia collusion was always a hoax
they knew it on five different levels
massive red flags were
littered all over the place but instead
of putting the brakes on their witch
hunt
they kept digging and digging and
digging blinded by this rage this hatred
desperate to take down the president
donald trump who they never understood
why he won because they didn't think of
it
and by the way their guiding light the
entire time
hillary clinton's russian bought and
paid for
unverifiable dirty dossier full of lies
a clear example of what is premeditated
fraud
conspiracy against trump members of his
campaign
and guess what on fisa courts all must
be held accountable
now thankfully truth did prevail four
separate investigations to date have
cleared the president
and his campaign of any and all
wrongdoing
and the hoax has been laid bare for all
to see and we will be giving you so much
more information
democrats in congress apparently they
haven't gotten the memo
gary nadler's clown show is in full
swing never ending stream of
frivolous subpoenas after failing to
haul in former white house counsel
don mcgann well then nadler issued
subpoenas for his chief of staff
even former aide hope picks who by the
way currently serves as an
evp at this network here at fox oh so
we're going to make hope pick spend
what another million dollars on lawyers
to answer the same exact questions
again only this time it will be a
perjury trap because god forbid
anyone that goes before congress they
got one minor
detail one little discrepancy that's
wrong or different from the last time
they testified
that's called the perjury trap now the
attorney general barr
defied a request to appear before
nadler's circus
and is now speaking out telling the wall
street journal quote i felt the rules
were being changed to hurt the president
president trump
and i thought it was damaging for the
presidency over the long
haul if you destroy the presidency and
make it
an errand boy for congress we're going
to be a much weaker more divided nation
democrats don't seem to care they're
still fuming and don't forget
clinton aid remember brian pagliano
hillary's aid
server chappaqua etc well
he totally ignored his 2016
congressional subpoena
related to the hillary email scandal
investigation
at the time democrats they could have
cared less again
selective moral outrage make no mistake
we are now witnessing
this selective outrage at its worst and
meanwhile jerry nadler circus is also
eager to feature oh they want robert
mueller to come in
democrats are hoping for one last round
of baseless trump
conspiracy theories and hoaxes they can
perpetrate
perpetrate on the american people but
team mueller
is reportedly reluctant to testify
publicly by the way probably for good
reason
now we'll have to answer in his case
very important questions
for example i'd like to know why mueller
why did he hire a team of
only democratic donors why did he
actually hire
hillary clinton's former attorney for
the clinton foundation why would he ever
give so much power to andrew weissman
hyper partisan hillary loving hack he
was at hillary's victory party
with an atrocious professional track
record
when did he realize that russia
collusion actually never happened
when did he learn about hillary's bought
and paid for
russian dossier and by the way to impact
the race
and that's important mueller needs to
answer if he had time to investigate
taxi medallions
decades-old tax returns bank fraud on
loan applications
perjury he didn't have time to look into
real evidence of collusion
because it featured hillary the heart of
his so-called mandate
and of course christopher steele
multiple foreign governments no time for
that either
and by the way i have some bad news for
democrats look at this new poll
most americans they are not interested
in mueller appearing before
congress they got it they read it it's
over
you just don't recognize a simple truth
the witch hunt is done
the only thing left now is yes the
second act that curtain goes up
but you'll have the radical base of the
democratic party out there calling for
impeachment even long into trump's
second term
nancy pelosi she's only speaker of the
house of name only
being pushed around by her colleagues
freshman congresswoman
socialist alexandria ocasio-cortez she's
the real speaker
and she's demanding that the president
be removed from office and nancy better
watch out and listen
alexander ocasio-cortez just caught up
with as well
and also said that this caucus should
not be hesitant
in moving moving forward with
impeachment
you know i i trust the speakers taking a
measured approach to ensure that we're
moving everyone forward i know that you
know being a speaker is part of holding
what you're watching there is nancy
pelosi speaker and name
only has lost all control in the u.s
house of representatives by the way sad
sight to really behold she is utterly
now powerless to the radical demands
from people like ocasio-cortez and
others
and according to a report from politico
massive infighting now taking place
among capitol hill democrats
and of course the infighting is already
in full gear
in the deep state congressman doug
collins who will join us in a moment
issued a massive document released
yesterday
hundreds of pages scores of closed-door
testimony transcripts
loretta lynch andrew mccabe so many
others and
thanks to this release we now know that
loretta lynch was
pretty much accusing james comey of
lying before
congress that would be lying before
congress testifying under oath
that she never asked comey to refer to
the clinton
criminal investigation as just a matter
the way comey said
somebody's lying somebody committed
perjury the only question now is was it
comey
or was it lynch or maybe both and coming
up we have a treasure trove of
developments
from these newly released transcripts
it's pretty clear the high-ranking
anti-trump officials in the deep state
they are scared and they are forming a
circular firing squad as the walls begin
to cave
in they know what they did they know
they're in deep trouble
and breaking tonight john solomon is
back with another bombshell new report
detailing yet another red flag in the
fbi's witch hunt
into the trump russia so-called
collusion according to john solomon
tonight investigative reporter for the
hill
state department official kathleen
cavaleck did in fact send the fbi a
salacious piece
of so-called intelligence from her
meeting which by the way was not
appropriate with christopher steele
only problem was that the intel was
total and complete
bs which could have easily been
disproven
with any simple level of verification
that never happened
several days later comey then used
steel's bs
as the basis for the fisa request and he
signed the first fisa application
now by the way a request he swore was
verified
says it at the top of the document and
accurate and true